in the past few days we've seen
organizations announce that they're
leaving valorant due to circumstances
regarding valorin's new partner program
a lot of people have referred to this as
franchising but it's not entirely
accurate there is a lot to discuss here
so let's talk about exactly what this is
and how it's going to shape the future
of competitive valorin
[Music]
hey guys it's Liz and I'm super excited
to announce we are going to be
co-streaming Evo August 5th 6th and 7th
at twitch.tv the score Esports your
girls flying all the way to Canada and I
am terrified of flying but I'm actually
super excited to watch the game split
the guys and get to meet everyone and to
hang out with you so I hope to see you
all there alright kiddos class is in
session the VCT is already incredibly
confusing and these changes did not help
so let's talk about exactly what is
going on here back in April Riot
announced changes that would be
occurring within the Valiant competitive
scene in Riot's Valiant partnership
announcement they said for 2023 we will
select partner teams across our three
international league so I have a track
record of building great Esports
experiences developing players and can
meaningfully contribute to the long-term
growth of ballerin Esports to make sure
we attract the best teams in the world
we will forego any participation
franchising fees and instead provide
Financial stipends to the selected teams
in return for their investment in
growing the ecosystem teams have since
applied and according to a dot Esports
report over 150 teams applied for this
partner program for a maximum of eight
spots in N A okay so let's get something
straight this is not franchising that's
technically the wrong word for it
franchising is essentially when an org
buys a spot in a centralized league and
has it until they want to sell it so no
like open qualifiers just play the
foregoing of franchising fees is in
contrast when Riot franchise the LCS
back in 2018. back then they charged
League of Legends teams a buy-in fee of
10 million dollars if you're not seeing
the difference basically you don't have
to pay for your spots in the valorant
partnership program it's like a college
application process for the US you
present all of your strengths admissions
officer and talk about your background
and hope that they pick you to be clear
we're not sure of relegation or if
demotion is possible in ballerin's
Partnership program daddy Sports is
already reported on teams who have made
the next round of the partnership
process and those teams are Sentinels
NRG TSM exit gen G version 1 and Cloud9
so far and according to the report on
the other side of the coin there are
teams who have already had to bow out
Shopify Rebellion made an official
announcement regarding their cut from
the program they said we're obviously
disappointed a popularity contest for a
woefully small number of Team slots in a
partnered League was always going to
leave too many on the outside looking in
a crew also made an announcement that
they did not make the cut and would be
temporarily leaving the valorance scene
what's going on everybody this is Daniel
the CEO of a crew I'm gonna come right
to it unfortunately we did not make it
to the next step of the evalard
partnership we really believe that Valor
is going to be the next big esport and
hopefully we'll get the chance to reiter
the scene when it's a little bit more
stable nyfu has also decided to pull out
a valrant completely leaving their
players lft teams not making it isn't
surprising but what is worrying is that
teams are deciding to leave the valorant
scene completely end players like your
boy Dre who are taking an indefinite
break from the game entirely this is all
completely understandable if your team
doesn't make it into franchising that is
one thing if you don't make the cut for
the partner program you could go to the
domestic League except you have no
information about what that is going to
be it is completely understandable that
you would not be comfortable with taking
the Financial Risk that comes with
committing to the tier 2 tier 3 scene
what I'm going to say next I mean with
all the love in my heart in the world to
these teams and these players I hope you
can understand that I'm trying to walk
the line of reality and sympathy not
every team was going to be in valorant
Forever eventually teams would have to
pull out because it's just not
sustainable even if there was no partner
program as Vincent Lee put it teams most
likely leave not every team was going to
commit to valorent however Riot promised
information regarding opportunity
outside of these partner teams but has
not given any information to
organizations teams nor players leaving
many wondering nervously about their
future which is why I believe Golden Boy
is correct when he says there needs to
be communication sooner rather than
later regarding what will happen to the
tier 2 Community Esports doesn't work
when it's built from the top down
Grassroots are key rise says that there
still will be third party torments but
that is not the format they have
promised as their path to Pro that
appears to be entirely separate they've
spoken about their domestic leagues and
we've seen that with barrels across the
world but again we do not have the
information about what that will look
like in an a we've seen success with
these in other regions to be fair emea
has seems like vitality and 10 star
competing in finals beginning July 28th
representing different Regional areas so
this is where we are at every day we are
closer and closer to finding out who
these partner teams will be and if the
reports are to be believed and they are
correct pretty much your usual suspects
emphasis on teams not Players Once teams
make it in things could rapidly evolve
and change and it looks like a plethora
of free agents will be available to
organizations to put it simply most
likely there will not be enough spots to
help house players we have grown to love
and support will it succeed will it fail
I don't know but there are some who wish
this wasn't the case at all some say the
steps being taken will end up
gatekeeping talented teams from
competing and even wish for its eventual
downfall and failure While others
disagree and say that's going to be fine
and egalitarian we won't know until it's
put into practice as I was writing this
and recording this more and more teams
like dark zero dropped out of the scene
and my gut says that after this video is
posted that Trend will continue
personally I don't see teams leaving the
scene stopping anytime soon I hope like
Aaron says that there is a healthy
ecosystem where the scene will grow and
continue to thrive and I hope that any
teams that leave will come back but that
is not a promised future call me
pessimistic but I will not celebrate
this partner program until I see support
for the teams that are chosen in real
tangible opportunities for players who
grind day and night to make it to the
top only then
will I celebrate the change
I want what I'm expecting from Riot
honest to God I want to see valorant
Players Association if the league team
can have League should and does have a
Players Association I want to Ballard
Players Association I think we would be
making a huge mistake
if there is not one in Valerie